F: *Clap* C'est parti pour un nouveau MentalVlog
Salut la Team Mentalo, aujourd'hui j'ai 2 sièges avec moi.
ce qui veut dire que je ne vais pas recevoir une personne mais deux personnes.
Et la 1ère personne c'est... c'est Raj
wouah mon dieu, il apparaît comme ça c'est incroyable.
Il y a un travail de Post prod, mon pote
C'est Raj de la chaîne autodisciple
R: ça va mon pote
F: Salut, On fait des checks... on sait pas faire des checks
R: On se lâche un peu
F: Il a eu le courage de dire "Oui" à tout pendant 30 jours
R: Ouais
F: Je ne dis pas de bêtises? tu m'arrêtes sinon.
R: Ouais.
F: durant 30 jours faire un "Yes Man"
En fait, pour ceux qu'ils veulent voir à peu près à quoi ça ressemble le...
la parodie qui existe là dessus c'est "Yes Man" justement avec Jim Carrey
R: Le film ouais
F: Exactement. Regardez, *tac* il se transforme en Jim Carrey
Exactement ça voilà.
*rires*
R: Tu vas vraiment le faire?
F: Et c’était moins barbu.. Oui bien sûr
R: Ah ouais
F: Oui
R: Ouais c'était inspiré de ça.
F: AH tu t'es inspiré du film?
R: Ben j'avais vu le film il y a longtemps, j'avais aimé. Je ne l'ai pas revu pour l'occasion mais... ouais ça vient de ça quoi
F: Et est ce ...
R: L'idée ne me serait pas venu autrement quoi.
F: D'accord
Et est ce qu'entre le film, l'idée que ça te provoque et le fait de le faire tu t'es renseigné un peu si, il y en a qui l'avait fait ou...
R: Euh non parce qu'en fait c'est un projet... d'habitude mes projets sont vachement réfléchis
F: Ouais
R: Et là en fait c'était une blague à la base.
C'est euh... quelqu'un m'a dit... ben Laetitia qui m'a demandé pourquoi je disais tout le temps "Oui" à tout
F: Parce qu'il y a une 3ème personne qui s'appelle Laetitia ici. Attends
R: Une 3ème personne *rires*
F: Coupons cette phrase et faisons là apparaître.
Accueillons tout de suite Laetitia
F: Mais je me lance dans la magie sur internet *rire*
L: Wouaaaahhh mais c'est ouf
*rires*
F: Laetitia de la chaîne 'La maison, Le corps, L'esprit'
pourquoi je fais apparaître Laetitia, parce que durant ce défi des 30 jours où tu as dis "Oui" à tout
R: Oui
F: Laetitia était présente, je te laisse reprendre ton explication, du coup, maintenant que tu es là.
R: Ben au début c'était un blague que je faisais à Laetitia, qui était très drôle.
*rires* elle disait "Mais pourquoi tu dis "Oui" à tout?"
et moi je disais "Que c'était un défi"
parce que souvent les gens se moquent de moi en disant "Ben tiens fait ce défi là", en disant des défis bêtes.
et moi je le reprend et j'ai dit "Oui c'est un défi de dire Oui à tout
et en fait c'est une blague que les gens ont vraiment cru
R: Tous les gens qui était avec moi ont vraiment cru que c'était un défi *rires*
L: Et moi j'y ai vraiment cru et j'étais trop à fond
R: Et ça a duré une semaine. Et au bout d'une semaine de blague j'ai commencé à dire que c'était pas vrai
mais je vais, quand même, le faire sérieusement pendant 30 jours.
F: Donc j'ai vraiment 3 questions à te poser
La première, c'est quand tu t'es lancé ce défi là, est ce qu'il y avais un objectif autre
que d'essayer de le faire et voir ce que t'en retirais?
R: Hum... j'ai pas vraiment réfléchi en fait, c'était toujours un peu une blague jusqu'au bout
*rires*
et surtout je m'attendais vraiment à avoir des trucs très négatifs comme dans le film.
F: Ouais
R: Dans le film, il y a un moment un SDF qui lui prend tout son argent, il lui vole sa voiture et tout.
et moi j'attendais de voir, en fait, si il y allait avoir des trucs très négatifs ou des trucs très positifs.
Finalement, il n'y a rien eu de très négatif.
mais dans ma tête c'était juste...
Ouais il y avait pas d'objectif, c'était juste de changer un peu la routine et de faire des trucs nouveaux
F: Ouais
F: Inversement, des gens qui savaient que tu étais en train de faire le défi, est ce qu'ils ont essayé d'en profiter et qu'est ce qui s'est passé?
R: Ben il y a eu plusieurs trucs. Franchement, déjà il y a eu plusieurs trucs des gens qui savent pas, dans l'ensemble, il t'arrive rien de grave
quand tu dis oui à tout. Et que tu dis à personne que tu dis oui à tout franchement il se passe pas grand chose de grave
le seul truc c'est... tu donnes de l'argent à tout le monde et tu achètes n'importe quoi
*rires*
F: Pourquoi je suis pas venu chez toi à cette période là ?!  *rires*
R: Mais dis toi que par exemple,
en fait le truc c'est ça. Il y a des gens qui te connaissent pas, donc eux ils savent pas forcément que tu fais un projet Yes Man donc ils te demandent rien de fou
et tu as les gens qui te connaissent mais à priori c'est plutôt tes amis
et eux ils te disent plutôt des trucs sympa en fait
moi j'ai pas mal d'amis qui m'ont demandé de l'argent
F: Ouais
R: Genre des grosses sommes tu vois
et à chaque fois je leur donnais 200-300 euros et en fait à chaque fois il me le rendait tôt ou tard
F: Ah oui d'accord
R: Ce qui est normal en fait quand tu réfléchis 2 secondes
F: Ben ouais mais c'est intéressant parce que, pour le coup, quand j'ai su que tu faisais le défi
comme tout le monde
premier truc que j'ai fais c'est de te demander un truc vraiment à la con.
R: Attends c'était quoi déjà
F: Ben je sais plus mais genre j'ai dû te dire "Ah bon ben finance mon nouveau spectacle", par exemple. Tu vois
R: Ok
F: Fais un crédit pour moi ou j'ai dû te sortir une vanne comme ça
et tu m'as fait oui
*rires*
F: Et du coup,
L: Et après t'es..
F: tu as un sentiment qui est ben Non
*rires*
F: En fait, après tu arrives pas à assumer
mais tu as pas fait des trucs comme ça avec lui?
L: Ben moi
F: Tu as pas essayé de jouer avec lui?
L: Ben en fait moi j'ai profité de son expérience, enfin j'en profite encore
R: Y a que elle qui a profité
L: Moi, je lui ai demandé de le continuer, donc il le continue pour moi et donc il a l'obligation de me dire oui à tout encore aujourd'hui
encore maintenant
*rires*
R: Non attends c'est pas exactement ça
L: Si c'est à peu près ça
mais le pire truc que je lui ai fait faire, c'est de monter avec moi à Bruxelles et de rentrer dans le complot de Bruxelles
F: Pour le projet Junker
L: Pour le projet Junker
F: Enfin Projet Junker c'est le nom de code du projet Junker, si vous avez pas vu ce qu'il s'est passé avec ça
et c'est pas possible que vous n'avez pas vu Laetitia, il y a eu, en quelques mots en fait,
il y a la commission européenne
en partenariat avec YouTube qui recevait 3 YouTubeurs de 3 pays
pour poser des questions à Junker le président on dit?
L & R: Le président de l'Union Européenne
F: Le Président de la commission européenne et ...
vous, vous avez filmé toute les coulisses de ça
L: Oui
puisqu'on te demandait plutôt un certain style de question, sans t'imposer de questions
L: C'est ça
F: Et toi tu voulais aborder d'autres sujets et on te faisait comprendre de pas les aborder
et au final durant le direct tu as posé tes questions *rires*
et je vous laisse découvrir ça directement sur la chaîne de Laetitia
L: J'ai fait une petite surprise à Junker et ça s'est bien passé.
F: Ouais ça s'est bien passé. Enfin, ... ça s'est bien passé... Oui
L: Et lui s'est retrouvé dans cette aventure là grâce à Yes Man
F: Exactement
R: Et c'est quand même un gros truc dans lequel je ne serais jamais arrivé si j'avais pas dit oui à pleins de trucs.
parce que ça ua final c'est normal que je dis Oui parce que c'était marrant quoi
mais j'aurai pas été avec toi à ce moment là, j'aurai pas été dans la dynamique de dire Oui à tout quoi
F: Oui c'est ça
R: Oui c'est ça en fait ça crée une dynamique
F: Tu aurais tout rationalisé, en ayant des chemins de décisions différents etc..
R: Ouais
F: C'est ça qui est intéressant dans ce truc quoi
R: En fait ça te fait pas mal voyager aussi
enfin moi j'ai un gars qui m'a proposé, qui m'a donné ces clés pour Barcelone
F: Ouais
R: qui a un appart à Barcelone, qui m'a dit "Ben vas y, vas y maintenant
si tu veux"
Et en fait c'est le moment où je me suis dit "Ah ben tiens c'est super ce projet je vais continuer à dire Oui et je vais vraiment le faire sérieusement, put*** ça donne que de bonnes opportunités"
et.. ça c'est le premier voyage que j'ai fait avec ça quoi
et après Bruxelles... c'est pareil c'est.. si j'avais fait un plan précis pour arriver à ce point là
en fait j'y aurai même pas pensé et j'y serai pas arrivé
F: Ouais
F: Alors que l'idée du Yes Man c'est aussi de...
permettre au hasard
d'amener des situations encore plus ouf que j'aurai forcément pu vivre autrement
F: Ouais c'est ce qui c'est passé, ça a fait un espèce d'escalier, comme ça et...
t'enlève n'importe quelles des marches, tu mets un "Non" quelque part et tout ce casse la gueule quoi.
F: Et est ce que tu avais des limites déontologiques à ton "Yes"?
R: Ben Non
F: Je t'aurai dit "Tue quelqu'un pour moi"
R: Ben techniquement j'aurai dû le faire quoi
après est ce que je l'aurai fait je sais pas
F: Ouais
R: J'espère pas *rires*
F: Ouais ouais
R: Mais en fait je me suis dit je veux vraiment le faire à fond
et ne pas avoir de limites du tout
F: En tout cas, je pense qu'ils sont bienveillants et je pense pour l'avoir ressenti avec toi
que au delà de la bienveillance après il y a les espèces de... barrières personnelles qui font que de toute manière tu as pas envie de faire de mal à l'autre
L & R: Ouais
F: Tu sais quand est ce que tu vas abuser
mais je crois que c'est très gênant pour l'autre
de se dire "attends il se met en position volontairement, si je le décide"
R: Ouais ouais
F: "qu'il est mon esclave"
R: c'est ça qui donne un pouvoir
F: "est ce que j'ai envie d'être ce mec là en fait"
tu vois parce qu'on parle toujours de
Ouais j'ai gagné, j'ai manipulé j'ai réussi ça
mais quand on te donne le libre accès
en fait ça devient, presque, gênant en fait ouais
R: Ouais puis peut être qu'au final c'est encore mieux qu'on me demande moins de trucs chiants
F: Ouais
R: Je sais pas
R: Parce que genre au début j'avais un peu envie de le cacher que je faisais ce projet Yes Man
et puis en me rapprochant de 2 semaines j'en avais un peu marre qu'il ne passe pas de trucs vraiment fou tu vois *rires*, donc je le disait à tout le monde en fait
et même quand tu rencontres des gens comme ça et que tu leur dit il te font rien faire, en fait, de fou
L: C'est vrai qu'on a eu des situations
on a eu des situations où on était dans le métro, on était avec des gens qu'on connaissait pas et on leur expliquait et il demande au gens dites moi de faire quelques choses
et les gens ils sont là: Ah ah ben non
en fait ils ont rien c'est drôle
F: Mais je dit c'est très gênant parce que
quand on obtient quelques choses de quelqu'un d'autre
en fait
on obtient l'acceptation de sa part
R: Ouais
F: Donc on sait que quoiqu'il arrive, il a accepté ça
R: Ouais ouais
F: Soit dans un schéma de peur de rationalisation ou d'envie
mais il a accepté
donc on est libéré de, comment te dire, on est libéré de.... mince je trouve pas mon mot
on est libéré de notre propre responsabilité de la demande
mais comme toi on sait que tu vas dire oui à tout
et que tu n'aura pas de chemin de décision, on est responsable de notre demande tu vois
et là, tu nous impose la responsabilité et du coup
dans la société actuelle, on est souvent dé-responsabilisé
on suit des règles, on suit un code de la route,  on suit les lois et
c'est comme ça tu vois ça nous rassure parce qu'on aime bien être cadré
et toi tu enlèves ce cadre là et du coup... ouais tu sais pas comment manipuler cette relation là
R: Surtout ça m'a fait réalisé qu'en fait les gens quand il te demande un truc ils veulent pas vraiment avoir ce truc
ils veulent l'avoir mais que tu es envie de le donner
F: Exactement
R: Si tu retires cette possibilité là
ben les gens ont pas du tout envie de te demander quoique ce soit
L: *rires* j'étais avec lui le jour où ça s'est arrêté
et il avait du mal à dire "Non"
C'était hyper drôle, j'ai les images où ...
R: Même encore aujourd’hui j'ai du mal à dire "Non"
L: Ouais parce qu'en fait c'était... c'est ce que tu avais expliqué, c'est que ça te prenait plus d'énergie en fait
L: Ça s'était intéressant
R: Ah oui le truc trop bien du Yes Man c'est: Tu réfléchis plus
F: Et oui, et oui
R: Pendant 30 jours j'ai pas réfléchi
vraiment quoi, tout ce que je faisais
c'était, j'attendais qu'on me demande des trucs et je le faisais quoi
et ça c'est des vacances incroyables quoi, c'est vraiment trop bien de faire ça
F: Ouais parce que toi, tu vois sur la responsabilisation dont je parlais tout à l'heure
toi aussi tu as viré toute part de responsabilités puisque tu as un chemin de fer et hop tu le suis quoi
L: Il s'est offert aux gens
R: Du coup, c'est bien parce que les choses que tu fais
tu les fais à 100% et avec enthousiaste
F: Je sais que tu as un autre défi en préparation, on en avait parlé ensemble.
R: Oui
F: On peut appeler ça Vérité absolue?
R: Honnêteté radicale
F: Ah oui
R: On peut appeler ça comme ça, parce que c'est le nom d'un livre et d'un concept de développement personnelle
F: L'honnêteté radicale. C'est marrant dans Lie to me dans les premières saisons il y a un mec qui était dans ce délire là, en fait, de l'honnêteté radicale
du coup, est ce que tu vas faire... enfin oui je pense connaitre la réponse mais est ce que tu vas faire une vraie honnêteté radicale
ou juste une honnêteté absolue?
Pour moi la différence c'est l'honnêteté absolue si tu me poses une question je te dis la vérité
l'honnêteté radicale, c'est que tu as pas forcément posé une question sur quelques choses et je vais te dire la vérité
Là par exemple, si j'en avais marre que vous soyez là, vous m'avez rien demandé et dans ces cas là au lieu de juste le ressentir je vais l'exprimer
R: Ouais ben c'est plus, ouais, l'honnêteté radicale c'est à dire aussi un truc émotionnel,
Enfin dire ce que tu ressens au moment où tu le ressent
F: Ok
R: C'est plus ça que... c'est pas juste un jeu, il y a un film avec Jim Carrey, du coup, aussi.
qui s'appelle Menteur Menteur
F: Ah oui, ouais, ouais
R: C'est pas vraiment ça parce que là c'est vraiment...
F: Le mec il fait tout les trucs de Jim Carrey
*rires*
F: Bientôt après il va faire sa vie en film dans un studio
R: Je vais faire The Mask c'est le prochain *rires*
F: Il va mettre un masque vert
R: Pendant 30 jours
*rires*
R: Et... là c'est plus effectivement il faudra dire la vérité aux questions de manière technique
mais aussi un truc émotionnel vraiment dire ce que tu ressens au moment où tu le ressens
F: Pour ceux qui voit pas un lien entre le mentalisme, le Yes Man et l'honnêteté radicale
euh... je vous plains
*rires*
F: Le lien il est direct, c'est l'évidence même et je suis à la fois intéressé et impressionné par le fait de le faire
parce que là il radicalise complètement des concepts...
Punaise radicalise avec ta barbe ça m'a fait peur *rire*
tu vois tu...
R: Non mais c'est l'idée, l'idée c'est de faire des trucs extrêmes pour revenir à une moyenne facile
F: Ouais c'est hyper intéressant de faire ça
L: De quoi?
F: De... ça
L: L'honnêteté radicale même pas en rêve
*rires*
L: Même pas en rêve, j'aime trop mentir tu es fou ou quoi
F: Je vous recommande vraiment, si vous avez 2 trucs à retenir c'est regardé la vidéo de Laetitia sur Junker qui est dans la description
Regardez la vidéo sur le défi du Yes Man sur la chaîne de Raj je la mets dans la descprtion
Et voilà, c'était une vidéo un peu rencontre différente comme on avait pu faire, il y a quelques jours, avec Clément Bonpoil qui est un synesthète
je sais pas si vous l'avez vu cette vidéo
R: Oui oui
L: Non
F: Tu vois il est pas encore dans le mensonge, alors il peut dire oui *rires*
R: Non mais c'est vrai en plus
F: Mais oui elle est cool. En fait c'est exactement ce que je voulais reproduire là
de me dire en fait j'ai la chance grâce à la chaîne de rencontrer encore plus de gens qu'avant
et des gens qui font des choses très spécifique
et c'est cool de pouvoir les partager avec vous.
Si ça, ça vous plait n'hésitez pas à nous le faire savoir en nous laissant un petit, véritable et Yes Man Pouce en l'air
ça voulait rien dire cette phrase *rire*
Mais voilà que si ça vous a plu, évidemment je ne force à rien. Blablabla
*rires*
Et n'hésitez pas à poser des questions aussi sur ce qu'on a raconté dans les commentaires, je me ferais un plaisir de vous répondre
par rapport au Yes Man etc... je sais que Raj et Laeti vont passer par là donc n'hésitez pas
R: J'y répondrai bien sûr
F: Ils ont dit qu'ils répondront
Si ils répondent pas ils n'ont pas de parole
*rires*
Et n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à cette chaîne là avant de partir
si ce n'est pas déjà fait et là j'en vois encore qui ont regardé pleins de vidéos qui sont pas abonnés.
Abonnez vous avant de partir.
Pourquoi parce que le MentalVlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an du 1er janvier au 31 décembre
donc rendez vous demain à 17h
Tchao !